for Republicans who believe it's time to
look to the future Marco Rubio is often
there man it takes every opportunity to
talk about offering a generational
change in this election we must change
the decisions we are making by changing
the people who are making them as the
youngest candidate in the race if only
just he can do that he has other assets
to a cuban-american hailing from Miami
would appear to deliver the Republican
Party the promise of votes from the
Latino community and the critical swing
state of Florida but Latinos don't vote
in one block and Rubio is having to
scrap with his former mentor the X
Florida Governor Jeb position and
someone has convinced me that attacking
me is going to help me he says this
election is about the future not the
past those are calculated swipes and the
Clintons and the bushes questions about
his own financial affairs do persist and
he did have to correct his own claims
that his parents escaped from Castro
they left years before the Revolution
whether any of this matters depends on
whether Republicans want the fresh face
he offers